for centuries it was the remoteness of
Brazil's indigenous communities that
protected them from the rapacious
outside world now it's what shields
those who are encroaching on protected
indigenous territory starting fires and
threatening the residents the Kari Puna
had their first contact with the outside
world in 1978
catch Iike talking her native language
translated for us into Portuguese
remembers it well she says they brought
diseases that decimated her community we
had a lot of land and we lived
peacefully now we live with fear that
are very few of us the invaders are
coming closer but that was just the
beginning the prospectors keep coming
Brazilian law says these cattle should
not be here and these fishermen are
trespassing on protected land but it
offers little protection in areas that
are so remote many of the fires started
by developers to clear vegetation burn
out of control it's difficult at first
to gauge why a place so remote so
tranquil should matter so much to the
rest of the world the indigenous people
who live here have always realized it
but now as the smoke fills the skies and
the ashes pollute the river the rest of
the world is beginning to realize it too
Breanna has been to Europe where he
asked the European Union and the United
Nations for protection protection from
Brazil's indigenous communities he says
is not being provided by their own
government biggest threats now are the
invasions the mission of the loggers of
the gold prospectors and recently
they've been a lot of fires in the
region around Kerry Puna territory and
that's affecting our lives because the
smoke is reaching the community his
brother Andre the village chief says
when the land goes the community dies
too we've been scared from the moment we
heard about the invasions from the
moment we reported it the neighbors have
said they want mine and my brothers
heads and when we've got them they'll
come for the rest to kill everyone
the Amazon fires have reminded the world
of the importance of preserving the
region but they're just another
consequence of the uncontrolled
unremitting more gradual destruction
being wrought in the interest of
development at the expense of this land
and the people who live here then you
swim their outer zerah carry Puna or on
dawnia's state northwestern Brazil